you brought up that it's it's a time for
people to laugh as a comic but also as a
citizen do you look at something like
Donald Trump and everything that
happened over the weekend with the tapes
do you look at it two different ways as
a comic and as a citizen or do you look
at it one way I look at it one way you
know in this particular case I said the
comedian aside and and the person you
know Kevin Hart the person simply simply
gets a little disgusted and the reason
why is because I think you can tell
Kevin Hart the person is uh I'm a
positive person you know I'm a person
that loves love and with that being said
I don't stand for segregation you know I
can't stand for dividing and-and-and
divide and conquer some what attitude I
know people that died with the hopes of
bringing people closer together and
making this world a better place and
those were hopes and once that were
taking this country in the right
direction and I feel like to take us
what seems to be backwards it's just
it's just unfair it's just misfortunate
and it shows why we're in the state they
were in now when people with that
mindset that attitude can make it as far
as he's made and have you here have to
ask about Jumanji first of all you just
hired a Jonas in Jumanji yeah Nick Nick
Jonas is in Jumanji man you know first
it's it's it's gonna be great we had a
couple of days off we won't be done
filming for quite some time but what I
want people to understand is that we're
not doing a remake of Jumanji this is
not a reboot you know what we're doing
is a continuation so if that world is
you mind you were to go on this is what
it would look like you would never
discredit that movie about lifting up
the hood and trying to read down what
we've seen we would just go on and try
to do something for this generation to
go oh my God look and and that's what we
were doing I spent the studio allowed to
do so dewayne of rock Johnson myself
Jack Black Nick Jonas
Karen McGill Ian we're all in here and
we're all doing a phenomenal job and
making a movie that we thought the world
was gonna love